there's there's been a lot of news about
inflation
and gas and it seems like the new news
cycle that's starting to bubble up we're
getting from politico from cnn from the
washington post and all these big
outlets is that there's going to be a
global food shortage or that we're
already experiencing one not to mention
inflation is through the roof so we've
got a couple stories about there's this
billionaire who owns a chain of grocery
stores and he said buy your food now
because it's going to get really
expensive soon they're saying that
basically because russia produces so
much fertilizer and now no one can trade
with them because of the war
we're going to see fertilizer costs
skyrocket availability diminish crop
yields will drop by 40
come fall is when everyone's going to
get hit by it that's the latest scary
news in the media and all has to do with
the war and that's going on so how you
guys doing so if if i can get a couple
million bats
and bat guano i can corner the market on
fertilizer yes okay
ian yes how do you feel about going
in on me in with me on a bad environment
we'll talk later we'll discuss graphene
and bats okay yeah yeah that's uh maybe
we do need a little bit of nationalizing
uh fertilizer what i don't know what
nationalizing food production never ends
well bro
what about that is a great way to murder
millions it's just gonna be
yeah
way cheaper than nuclear weapons
socialize socialized agriculture is the
best way to kill that's actually a
really good point you know we we worked
so hard on nuclear weapons to kill tons
of people when all we needed was
communism yeah exactly the united states
should have didn't even need to drop
bombs on japan we could have just
dropped communist pamphlets and then
communism and always like the
agriculture is such a good microcosm for
that of like what the soviets would do
is they'd go uh okay we need more we
need more crops so uh we're gonna order
all of the farmers you've gotta tilt
twice as much land now and the farmers
went yeah okay and they just lifted up
the the uh the the what do you call them
the the rudders the rudders are the
tractors you could tell i'm a farmer
they lifted up the rudders and then they
just drove really fast they just raked
the top of it because they don't have a
any any personal gain in it and then
like of course that meant that all of
the the bushels of wheat declined and
everybody started starving to death in
ukraine the other the other thing they
would do is they would go to the guy who
knows how to farm kill him yeah and then
take someone who did not have a farm and
put him in charge cambodia is a great
example i mean cambodia they literally
first like cambodia they shot anybody
that had any kind of education they just
shot to the point where if you had
glasses ian you'd be up against the wall
this is pol pot yeah was he like a
subject of mal or was he a friend of mao
or inspired by mao or something he
wasn't sp not only was he inspired by
mao he this is literally the name of
cambodia's communist program was the
super great leap forward not the great
leap forward but the super greatness it
was my idea and they killed about a
quarter of the population doing that and
they literally they'd go okay the annual
crop yield of the average hectare of
farmland in cambodia let's say it's like
eight bushels or something they went all
right from now on everybody has to do 40
bushels and people would go uh hi i'm a
steve door i don't know how to farm and
also there's a bunch of rocks here and
like that was it and like it did it
caused massive massive death
yeah that was the funny thing where um
was it mao he was like kill the sparrows
was that yeah and then everybody locusts
yeah yeah yeah this is why don't let
commies near food yeah
no no i mean
shout out shout out to maduro oh boy oh
yeah he did a great job there when he
was giving his national address and then
just pulls an empanada out from a drawer
and bites it really slowly and then puts
it back on tv for everyone to watch this
is how great capitalism is because
capitalism is like what are we worried
about getting fat that's what we're
worried about with capitalism is excess
twinkies that's how great
we just produce all this stuff yeah i
saw aoc has a new asmr video out
i don't know if you guys saw it she's
like whispering she's like no wait are
you serious stop it yeah she's legit
whispering into this no you're not she's
like me no i'm not are you serious yes
aoc did asmr i don't know if you were
just like just whispering yeah okay it's
just whispering and she was like people
don't realize they're actually
socialists because no one's a capitalist
because no one has a billion dollars
what and i'm like how that's what the
word means you know i i don't i i i was
like gonna tweet something that was like
mean and then i was just like she's got
a dictionary right because that's not
what capitalism means technically she
has a degree in economics that's the
thing that really
she clearly didn't sit through any of
the classes that drives me nuts because
i'm gonna spend the rest of my life
having just go no the definition of
socialism is the government owns the
means of production that's the
definition of social media doesn't mean
sharing that would make the koch
brothers socialists but what you failed
to realize is that the definition of
capitalism is you have a billion dollars
that's right that explains it sheamus
you're so smart yeah well i'm glad i
could inform you so in communism they
own the production socialism they also
own the production what's the difference
there there's actually debate about that
diff the distinction between communism
and socialism some people say that
communism is the end state and socialism
comes in between others say that
communism was the gut is when the
government completely controls culture
and economy whereas in under socialism
they're just controlling economy it
isn't really
let me tell you what the lefties say
they say socialism is an economic system
and communism is a political system in
socialism you can have a variety of
social issues you can have a variety of
um you know like church or gay marriage
but the economic system is the means of
production are owned by the people and
they believe in full out socialism
there's like there's no you know there
would be no um i don't say no currency
but there's no like private trade of
goods whereas communism is everyone's
equal
on every on every issue and then so uh
communism includes issues like gay
marriage whereas socialism is just
economic that's why would it be like
socialism is to communism as capitalism
is to democracy yeah but that that is a
no
capitalism's the economic state and
democracies the governmental political
state not necessarily i mean capitalism
can exist under multiple systems sure
yeah yeah
but there are many who argue democracy
and capitalism are opposed to one
another yeah yeah saying uh yeah exactly
like socialism and communism are uh
socialism is a large component of
communist ideologies like you can't
exist one can't exist communism cannot
exist without socialism yes but we're
also approaching this as westerners from
a liberal democracy because as sheamus
rightly points out the commies didn't
think this way like if you go back and
you look at soviet manifestos like but
like back in the 80s like you see like
uh
the the soviet premier would say we
believe we can achieve communism in the
next 10 years right so like to an
american that sounds very odd for the
soviet union to say it's not it's not
communist but the way commies thought
was socialism is our economic policy
communism is when the withering of the
state occurs and the proletariat becomes
the kind of the end-all be all right
like we the last 30 years we've made a
distinction of socialist countries are
socialist countries that are cute that
we like and communist countries or
socialist countries that we find scary
yeah and and capitalism for those that
don't know is literally just when
private individuals have the ability to
trade amongst each other yeah yeah the
private sector
meaning charity individuals and
corporations it means that
capitalism would be you as an individual
decide that your labor has value and you
decide what you're willing to exchange
it for in socialism you don't get to
decide what your labor is worth you just
get what's available i mean central
planners determine where your labor
should be allocated and to your point
this is why you constantly hear commies
saying that real communism has never
been tried because they're talking about
a theoretical end state which has never
existed communism they sure killed a lot
of people trying to get there yeah
exactly
they did some heavy lifting to try and
get there yeah also this is hilarious
because they say communism works and
they say real communism has never been
tried and how on earth could you know if
it works if it's never been tried it
sounds like they tried it for a hundred
years and failed it just yeah they
failed to achieve their end goal well
you could i mean like like
sounds so weird for me to say i think
they could be right if
you tried it with 150 people and anybody
in that group could leave whenever they
want it but but then communism because
it's not it's not endorsed no no no no
no
absolutely like a family's communist
we've talked about this in the past
unlike it's like the valence levels of
behavior in your family it's very
communist to each the
fire departments are not socialism
police department social programs are
not socialism socialism is when the
factory is owned by the state yeah
having like the fire department it's
owned by the city
so you having some components of
emergency services that are provided to
you through social services is not
socialism it's not socialism
you can call it social welfare program
hybrid this is what happens with uh
denmark and and you know bernie sanders
is like the socialist and then the truth
and then the prime minister comes out
and he says no we're not the prime
minister flew to america to remind he's
like no we are actually a market economy
we're a market economy that has a robust
welfare state exactly which is a nuance
that is very much lost on bernie sanders
who has converted the word socialism to
mean sharing so yeah is the fire
department part like welfare is it
considered welfare i would i would say
you could say that in a sense yeah well
first of all fire department actually
varies quite a lot in the united states
about half of the fire departments in
the united states are private voluntary
organizations uh about half of them are
some combination of publicly funded and
things like that so the idea that all
fire departments are a public government
organization the same way like police
departments are would be a misnomer um i
think i don't know i i could kind of
like i could kind of go either way on
that because like theoretically an army
could be a mercenary army right but we
don't we don't tend to have those we
tend to have uh you know an actual
military that that is paid for by by
taxpayers and things you can have uh uh
like bodyguards and things like that so
fire departments aren't producing things
they're emergency services so i think
it's fair to say there's a distinction
between you open up a cracker factory
and the government's like no no no we
control how this operates because it's
going to be equal
you would make the distinction between
economic productivity or just economic
production versus services
well not necessarily services because
services could be anything i mean
delivery services the post office i just
think it's fair to say that uh the fire
department is not socialism the fire
department isn't the means of production
it's emergency services so emergency
services are different from services the
post office is not an emergency service
the post office we could argue should be
privatized you know fedex and ups are
better i argue that quite a lot actually
i guess yeah occasionally people will
call me from npr and be like you wanna
come talk about this there are there are
some questions about uh why the fight
why it's important the fire department
be sort of nationalized sort of uh
private a lot of areas that have
volunteer fire departments they do
because they don't have the resources to
sustain large salaried fire departments
but one of the one of the issues with
fire departments as to why it might make
sense to have it be sort of like you
know look we're going to cover all fire
is because fire spreads right and if the
police department showed up and said
this guy doesn't pay us right we don't
service him it's like what are you going
to do put the fire out for the buildings
next to it no we're all too close to
each other you put the fire out and what
to figure it out yeah that's i'm that
those are negative externalities are a
legitimate role for government in my
opinion you know like if you've got like
smog smog doesn't obey property lines
right so like that's a situation where
it makes sense to have some kind of
adjudicating service but if i want to
make and sell shoes
having the shoe department where you've
got to go apply at the government office
and then pass some you know affirmative
you know action test or you know
diversity test and then they allow you
to be a shoemaker that's a problem
and if there were a federal shoe
department and you and i came in and
went you know we think the private
sector could probably handle this people
would think we're monsters if i said we
should privatize the federal shoe
department because the the milwaukee
public factory makes way too many left
shoes and the uh the oregon factory
makes insufficient right shoes we're
making people wear two left shoes i
think the private sector can handle this
people would go you want people to walk
around barefoot in america and you're a
monster you know the problem with the
department of education people want that
ended and i think privatized or at least
sent around localized is that
when you it's no longer federalized then
how do you or how do you organize it how
do you make sure everyone's getting like
a similar shoe size how do you make sure
that your size 11 is the same as his
size 11 if you're at different companies
with no government over arguably it's
not doing it now right i mean the
federal government basically just tries
to bribe state education departments
with grants like with uh no child left
behind and that kind of thing but the
actual government or the actual
curriculum is still done at the state
level and the funding is done at the
local level yeah exactly i mean the
department of education has only been
around since the late 1970s so it's not
as if this is integral to a public
education system and even if it was it
would still probably be bad because our
public education system is horrible yes
i think massey said it would free up 400
million dollars a year again flip it if
the if the private sector if we just had
like charter schools that was all the
schools in america right now and we were
looking at test scores people would go
man the private sector has really failed
we need to we need to change this but
when the government does it we never go
man i'm sure screwing this up we should
privatize this yeah well so that's the
way i describe it is with these social
programs
uh well i'll i'll start by saying all
laws should have sunset clauses you know
all bills being passed through congress
and the same is true for all social
programs i like the idea that we're like
okay we got a serious issue right we've
got mass homelessness we're going to
need a major public works program that's
fine to me as long as it's got like a
finite limit on when it expires because
what happens is they come out and they
say
we need a department of education we
need public schools because we need our
kids to be educated and then a few years
goes by and the kids are suffering and
doing worse and so the way i describe
this is the united states with a
festering wound they slap a bandage on
it they say we'll just cover that up
with a nice little bandage and then a
few years goes by and they look at it
now it's smoldering and infested and
worse and they say let's just put
another bandage on top of that and just
what they do is they keep dumping money
into failing programs
so you think they're fixing it but
they're not really fixing it yeah right
so they're saying hey we're going to fix
it with this money and you go oh thank
you and then you walk away and then they
don't actually fix it they make it worse
you can't falsify that either like if
we're going to approach policy making
scientifically you can't disprove a
negative right uh like like if any any
government program you ever put out
there
fails the proponents of it can go it was
insufficiently funded that applies
literally every single time yeah we
failed so give us more money it would
have worked if you've given us money
because but there's never going to be
enough money for everybody to have what
they want yeah it's hilarious you see
you see political leaders do this a lot
too like i didn't achieve everything i
was supposed to in my first term which
is why you need to give me a second you
know what like sometimes it can be
legitimate i just want to mention this
one milton friedman quote that there is
nothing so permanent as a temporary
government you know what
abolish the government just get rid of
it all yeah does it fall whole thing
abolish government yeah i just i want a
boutique
i want a little like compact nobody no
government for anybody nobody gets any
government i'm gonna fall apart it's
none
am i the statistic
i think there should be a government i
just think it should basically protect
us from bears and maybe communists we
need an agile government that changes
when the technology changes like we
should be working more online the
government's so slow to adapt they're so
happy getting their paychecks and just
going to work
here's where i did i actually think
government's too quick to adapt i wish
they they moved a lot more slowly than
they did when powdered wigs when was
like the first paper on graphene
that i ever saw no just like what what
that you can think of like the first
thing big 2004 is when it was done
discovered so so we're looking at what
and the us government has not bee is not
made of graphene i've never heard of
someone in the government mentioned the
word unless they're sitting across from
me and i say it to them and then they
repeat me it's crazy every opportunity
yesterday whenever we have a politician
and or you know ian's like graphene like
now's my chance you guys should be
looking at this
as if the best government in the world
to produce the most miraculous substrate
and the planet earth thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there